i'm a theorist we write down our
equations
you know in that equation this is the
equation come to life this is what this
is what i love about it this this is an
equation come to life this is not just
you know a bit of differentiation a few
greek symbols
this is those equations in reality this
could be this could reveal extra
dimensions this could reveal super
symmetry this could reveal you know the
origin of dark matter
you know this machine it's not just an
equation that i've written down on a
piece of paper anymore this is
this is it this is really looking for
stuff this is incredible
we're just about to go into atlas
and but just before we go in we can see
there's this this big mural on the
outside i quite like it actually i think
i think it's pretty good i think it's uh
yeah it's not it's nothing because he's
still just there no i know because we
were arguing about this yesterday brady
and i i said i thought it was uh i quite
liked it
because then you'll know i didn't like
it
the other thing uh of interest that we
we we can see it in the background you
see those big tubes they contain helium
and that's the helium that gets used to
cool down the the silver conductors and
then the magnets
yeah so so this is the this is the main
control room here at atlas normally this
would be very busy but of course we're
on shut down at the moment but one of
the important people that's still here
is that lady over there with the green
cardigan who's the the safety person so
she's making sure that nothing goes
belly up while we're down there and and
also she's basically the most important
person here
and again
so we had to stop digging somewhere up
here and and hold the walls in
class let's see what happens here that's
right
steve yeah
could you please close the mud
it's enormous
it really is enormous what do you think
i think it's incredible it's the sheer
scale of it is just what what hits you
first time
i mean it really is huge i mean that's
30 is across apparently but i don't
think that does it justice you know when
you're actually here and you can see how
truly big it is
i mean it's it's vast
you know and it's kind of i think it's
crazy if you think that
you know it's so big
and yet we're looking at something so
small and it's just the sort of paradox
of the whole thing but because you need
that
those things are incredible
a typical collision produces many
hundreds of particles and each component
of the atlas detector is necessary to
build a full picture of the collision
this is where the collisions are taking
place or one of the places where the
collisions are taking place along the
lhc
and you'll you'll see up here
if i just look at that blue bit that
where that blue encasement is that's
where the beam is the protons are coming
in from this side
and then they meet protons coming from
the other side and they collide right in
the middle of that that big detector so
that's where all the stuff's going on
inside there
so the bit that we see here is called
the uh the muon spectrometer
to actually see what's going on inside
the detector we'd have to move this out
we'd literally have to pull this out and
they do do that i'll just be told they
do do that
then you've got sort of some magnets
behind that and then you literally have
to pull another wheel out and then you
got access to all the calorimeters for
example the electromagnetic calorimeter
the hydron color limiter
and within that you've got the the inner
detector and the pipe itself so
literally it's deep within that is where
all where it's all going on where it's
all kicking off well
this is this is where a lot of the
information you know we learn about a
lot of the information in precisely this
part this is where the muons the muons
are uh are coming through this is we
then an awful lot from the what the
muons are doing
in particular if you look at these sort
of these triggers here this is all these
you know the sort of copper coloured
parts
those are the triggers you know they can
detect the position of these muons down
to you know the timing of the muon
passing by down to accuracy of a
nanosecond so these are all these are
remarkably accurately telling us where
and when these muons are passing through
as a muon passes through these tubes it
leaves a trail of electrically charged
ions and electrons which drift to the
sides and center of the tube what's
what's special is is how the muon's
behaving the muon you know has it
perhaps lost a little bit a little bit
less energy than you might have thought
all the energies don't add up
and then you know you've got a lot of
these muons you've got a lot of these
different events going on you add up the
energies and say let's say you've got
some missing energy well
that would tell you something that would
tell you that maybe where's that energy
gone maybe the energy's escaped into an
extra dimension maybe you've produced a
dark matter particle there's various
things that that could mean and that's
uh so you learn an awful lot just by
adding up all these little bits so
actually the higgs event that was that
we think may have happened just before
christmas
that actually i would have not got out
this fog
okay because what that was was a higgs
decaying into into two photons those
photons would have been absorbed by the
electromagnetic calorimeter which is
right in the center of all that it's the
first calorimeter outside the inner
detector so you know they would have
been absorbed at that stage they would
have been given a little glow you know
and essentially they would have been
spotted at that point so there would
have been you know i mean it would have
been stuff coming out but it it's not
the stuff that we would have been
interested in at that stage so tony if
the higgs event can be detected deep
within
why do you need this muon detector all
the way out here because you need
knowledge of the entire event of
everything that's going on i mean you
know in any in any one collision you
know there's an awful lot of stuff
happening right so you've got okay you
will have muons flying out well that's
not the stuff you're interested in you
have to know the full picture to know
what's going on deep inside that's the
important
thing so we're in a really noisy bit now
as you can probably tell i'm having to
just shout because that thing's making a
racket you know it really makes you feel
like you're really in the heart of this
machine now i mean of course where we're
stood now you won't be able to stand
when this thing's on too much radiation
flying around too many particles that
could do you know some serious damage
so obviously and apparently these walls
are seven meters thick so you know this
is really all well encased
i should talk about the the you know the
pipe itself and what's going on in there
you basically got
protons whizzing around at nearly the
speed of light you know they're doing
that circuit of the of the um of the
cardia
eleven thousand times a second you know
and they need to do that for about half
a day and in that time they would have
traveled almost to the to the distance
of neptune so this
you know they really get they're really
bombing it and they you know they're
really carrying each one is only
carrying the energy
of a mosquito in flight which doesn't
sound that impressive so you know we're
building all this sort of
this great big kit and yeah we're we're
making these um
these protons giving them the energy of
a mosquito
but i guess that might not sound
impressive but you think about how small
the the proton is right that's what's
interesting i mean if i if i clap my
hands right there's more energy in that
collision than in any given collision up
there
okay but of course it's occurring over a
much larger region of space
now just to see how that makes a
difference when you shrink things down
you know if i had a needle attached to
there then i would think twice about
hitting that so hard so that sort of
emphasizes the point that you know
squeezing things down makes a real
difference i mean i mean this beam right
it's coming around it's about
a centimeter thick
right and then when it cut when you get
to this point where it's gonna it's
gonna hit the chamber it's gonna it's
basically gonna collide they need to
squeeze that beam right right down right
right down down to a heads breath and
then you get this collision okay now
you've got in each bunch you've got
about 10 to the 11 protons
okay
and yeah in any given
collision event
only about 20 of those actually collide
what happens to the rest of them well
they just carry on
no worries they just carry on obviously
that's the vast majority right do you
think in fact this is one of the
remarkable things you've got these
each collision 10 to the 11 protons 20
of them actually involved in in a
natural event
and then of those events
most of them are thrown away as i said
you know we talk about a billion events
per second
we're only interested we only keep data
about 100 of those
okay because most of the stuff we know
about stuff we're not like interested in
so literally 20 out of 10 to the 11
actually do something interesting
and then out of those we've been off the
vast majority as well so actually the
ones that are actually going to give you
say higgs event is sort of you know
literally it's like winning the lottery
they're so unlikely what happens to the
other protons after the ones that miss
out on the collision well they go round
again
and they go around again and they go
around again and of course most of the
protons will never get a chance to be
involved and will never be involved in a
collision most of them won't be
but uh and then eventually after about
half a day
they decide to dump the beam
and they basically just get go so beamed
off and they just smash the beam into
you know essentially a wall and they
just dump out the energy well then they
just they generate some new protons and
start the whole procedure again those
ones are gone they're done they're done
with they missed their chance
so we've just we've just taken the
elevator up from from the basically the
ground floor of the of the detector up
to this higher bit so you can actually
looking down on the on the beam pipe now
and we're at the top of the detector uh
they told us as well there's actually an
elevator which drops right into the
center of this thing as well so uh it's
not the only elevator we haven't been in
that one we've been in the service one
there that we've used
if any of these keys are missing
the lhc cannot switch on right so it's a
safety thing essentially so if i take
this back to back to nottingham with me
the lhc is not going on uh it's very
important i put this back on the other
way out so it's also it's quite
reassuring that i've got it in my hand
because that thing ain't going to switch
on while i've got this in my hand so
that's good
this is it it's the detector we're here
and you've got the beam comes in
and it goes into this monster it's noisy
it's it's like if you've been on a on a
ship on um
you know across across the english
channel or something and you're on
you're on the the hum of the engines
constantly that's what you can hear and
you
and you can just see people i mean you
just get an idea of the size of it there
are two people here
and i don't this
it's uh